ALAN SEALES: So, OK, Sam.
SAM ESMAIL: Yes.
ALAN SEALES: You used
to be a hacker, yes?
SAM ESMAIL: Yeah.
ALAN SEALES: Would you
call yourself that?
SAM ESMAIL: I don't
know because I
don't want to offend real
brilliant hackers out there.
I was a very bad one.
I got caught doing
simple email spoof.
And I got a busted
on that because they
traced the IP to my computer
lab job that I was working on.
I am a very, very bad--
I used to be very, very
bad low-level hacker.
CHRISTIAN SLATER: Did guys show
up at your house after that?
Or--
SAM ESMAIL: No, I just got fired
and put on academic probation.
ALAN SEALES: So, does the NSA
know you're here right now?
Do we need to worry about that?
SAM ESMAIL: There's a file.
There's definitely a file.
ALAN SEALES: Right.
SAM ESMAIL: Very small file.
ALAN SEALES: So,
the show itself--
does very poor hacking.
So the show itself deals,
primarily in my opinion,
like with the inequality,
financial inequality,
between 99% and the 1%.
Like where did this
come from in your mind?
SAM ESMAIL: Well, I said I was
like one of those angry nerds
in high school, right?
Where you read-- like you
were like Holden Caulfield
and, fuck the man,
that kind of thing.
And there was something
about that angst
that I thought it was
always interesting.
And you know, so I'm Egyptian
and I have a lot of family
over in Egypt.
And they had just gone
through the Arab Spring,
and they have that kind
of spirit too that caused
this revolution over there.
And there is something
about this anger
channeled in this
real positive way
to bring about change that I
thought was really interesting.
And so when I go back to
99% thing and the income
inequality, that's
frustrating a lot of people.
And there's a lot of
anger around that.
And there was the whole
Occupy Wall Street
Movement around that.
So I just took that as more of
a way to build the character.
This kid--
ALAN SEALES: Have you been
working on this since--
for now back with--
SAM ESMAIL: Well,
no, because I mean
I've always wanted to, because
I think the hacker culture is
actually really interesting.
I grew up knowing
a lot of hackers.
And watching television
movies about hackers
is incredibly disappointing.
CHRISTIAN SLATER: Frustrating.
Frustrating.
SAM ESMAIL: Really, really.
Yes let's go through
with frustrating.
CHRISTIAN SLATER: Let's
go with frustrating.
ALAN SEALES: Well, you don't
want to reroute the encryption
and bypass the mainframe?
Oh, look I downloaded.
I fixed it.
SAM ESMAIL: Although I do like--
have you ever seen the movie,
"Hackers"?
ALAN SEALES: Yeah, yes.
SAM ESMAIL: I mean it's--
ALAN SEALES: It's horrible.
SAM ESMAIL: It's horrible.
ALAN SEALES: I'll
put it out there.
SAM ESMAIL: OK.
But I do love it.
But any way, so I really had
always wanted to do movie,
televisions show about hacking.
And I would say, when the
financial meltdown happened,
I was pretty, I would
say, offended would
be the nice way of putting it.
And I remember it started
inspiring the character.
But then about a
couple years ago,
is when I infused it with this
whole idea of a hacker who
sort of had that point of view.
ALAN SEALES: Interesting
so, Christian, you look just
like the guy from "Archer."
CHRISTIAN SLATER: Oh, yeah.
Slater.
ALAN SEALES: So did
you do the role?
I mean do you have background
with any sort of technology
like this either?
Or you're just kind of
pulling out your acting chops?
CHRISTIAN SLATER: Yeah,
I'm digging deep here
with a lot of this stuff.
Yeah, I mean our joke was that
I was hack proof because I
had one of those light-proof
cases around my iPhone.
ALAN SEALES: The Otter cases?
CHRISTIAN SLATER: Yeah,
I had one of those.
I was like, I'm perfectly safe.
But I just made the
switch to a Mophie.
I can't make that joke anymore.
But, yeah, so
technology- I mean,
I have a computer, of course.
And I've gotten better, but
as we were making the show,
there are moments,
where I'd be like,
what's this the
abbreviation here?
CPU?
I needed some help.
ALAN SEALES: AFK.
CHRISTIAN SLATER: AFK.
Yeah there were
things like that,
where I was a little
out of my depth.
SAM ESMAIL: But he
said them really well.
CHRISTIAN SLATER:
Yeah, I enunciated.
Yeah.
"Ska-dah."
ALAN SEALES: Yeah,
though, working
with the younger actors--
CHRISTIAN SLATER: I just Binged
the definition and I was fine.
All right, all right, all right.
Where am I?
ALAN SEALES: So working with--
CHRISTIAN SLATER: He
set me up with that.
SAM ESMAIL: Yeah,
ALAN SEALES: Shh,
don't tell him that.
So working with the
younger actors then,
is it good for you, fun
for you, or different,
because the younger
actors grew up--
CHRISTIAN SLATER: I hate it.
No, of course.
I love it.
They're great.
Rami is amazing, right?
SAM ESMAIL: He's terrible
at technology, too.
ALAN SEALES: Is he really?
SAM ESMAIL: Don't think
just because he's younger--
CHRISTIAN SLATER:
Yeah, it's all illusion
that these guys are so skillful.
And we rely on Sam--
SAM ESMAIL: And I
rely on other people.
CHRISTIAN SLATER: --and
other technical people.
When we first got the
script, we did that scene
on the Ferris wheel, it was
like an eight page script
and there were a
lot of definitions
in there, root kits and a lot
of different technical terms.
And I'd worked on the scene.
I had memorized
it, that I really
wanted to get all
those terms just right.
And then he met with
another technical expert,
who then updated those terms.
SAM ESMAIL: It screwed
up his whole scene.
CHRISTIAN SLATER: It made it
a little bit more confusing,
figuring out IP addresses
and the right numbers to say
was tricky.
ALAN SEALES: So you're
getting at least getting
a better grasp of it now.
CHRISTIAN SLATER:
I'm starting to.
ALAN SEALES: You know
what an IP address is.
CHRISTIAN SLATER: I think so.
SAM ESMAIL: Yeah,
so we're talking
about filming on the
Ferris wheel though, like,
you filmed in New York.
CHRISTIAN SLATER: Right.
ALAN SEALES: So what
are the challenges?
CHRISTIAN SLATER:
Greatest city of all time.
[APPLAUSE]
Working here is the greatest.
And we're shooting
at Silver Cup Studios
so I can still smell
Alec Baldwin's cologne
from "30 Rock."
His presence is
definitely there.
He's left a mark.
You know, Tina Fey, all
those people were there.
So just to be able to walk
around and take the subway.
I take the E train
right over the--
and it's a two-minute
walk to the studio.
So it's thrilling.
And then the offices of F
Society were at Coney Island.
So that was amazing.
ALAN SEALES: Well,
which I did actually
look on Google Maps
for the address
It is not what it's
supposed to be.
So I'm disappointed.
So I looked up
psychiatrist's Facebook page,
which is not real and looked up
the address, which is not real.
CHRISTIAN SLATER: Genius.
ALAN SEALES: You're at Google.
Of course, we fact check here.
So those were not real,
but in terms of-- I'm
trying to find my card
with all this on there.
BlackBerry, Steve Jobs, Hunger
Games, Facebook, Josh Groban,
Maroon 5, Gchat, you
use so many brand names
that makes it-- pulls
me in personally
and I feel like I have a
better connection to it.
And I guess being technological,
I relate more to it a little
more too.
But at the same time, it's
almost comic book-esque
in that you have such an obvious
approach to the evil side.
Like, name is Evil Corp, right?
Which looks like a cross
between Enron and Dell.
Was that on purpose?
SAM ESMAIL: No, it
is the Enron logo.
ALAN SEALES: Oh, is it?
SAM ESMAIL: We just took it.
I don't think anybody's going
to be fighting for that logo.
It was easy to get.
Oh, my god.
ALAN SEALES: Like at what
point where you said,
I'm going to make
this as real as I can
and then make it as
obviously fake and evil?
SAM ESMAIL: Well, that
was an interesting one.
Because there's the line in
there where he reprograms
his mind to see, think, and
hear, Evil Corp every time
he sees the name of the company.
And I had one
point said, we were
going to bleep out the
name of the company.
We would never actually hear
the name of the company.
And you would just hear
Evil Corp in the show
because that's
Elliot's point of view.
But then I was just like,
you know, it's Evil Corp
and the more I got used
it, the more I was like,
I think people, when
watching the show,
I don't we stylize in such
a way that they're like,
they're are too over the
top or anything like that.
I think we still kind of keep
it in the grounded world.
But the names is Evil
Corp. I don't know.
I just kind felt fine with it.
ALAN SEALES: It made sense
to me because Elliot talks
to the audience, which is
a character in the show.
And it felt like talking--
SAM ESMAIL: With an
imaginary friend.
ALAN SEALES: So it
was interesting to me
that he explained like,
this is Evil Corp. This
is what we call them and then
from that point on, that's
what they always were,
which was very interesting
and it fit to me.
I realized at the end
of the show that I said,
oh, they never actually
said what the real name was.
And I didn't care.
Right.
So good job.
Good job with that.
So Elliott, I'm
going to quote him.
Here.
After the opening scene
in the coffee shop
he says, "In three
short minutes,
I've destroyed a man's
business, life existence.
I deleted him."
The language that Elliot
uses is very deliberate.
And it's almost a
dichotomy against what
your character says as well.
Because Elliot has
social anxiety.
He's got some social
issues and of course, I
assume that was
on purpose, right?
SAM ESMAIL: Correct,
ALAN SEALES: Like from
personal experience?
SAM ESMAIL: Yes.
ALAN SEALES: So how
does your character--
you seem a little bit smarter,
a little bit more aware, much
more socially inept.
CHRISTIAN SLATER: That's nice.
ALAN SEALES: Like
the character is.
CHRISTIAN SLATER: The character.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
CHRISTIAN SLATER: Let's
just be clear about that.
Not Christian Slater but
Mr. Robot is definitely more
socially aware.
ALAN SEALES: Right.
CHRISTIAN SLATER: But
the question iis--
ALAN SEALES: Yeah, so the
question is-- no, I just
want to stop right there.
So the question is
how much of that
is on purpose, I guess from
the writing and how much of it
is acting choice and how
you present the character?
CHRISTIAN SLATER:
Well, let's see.
I think the age
factor I think, is
this is helpful there, that I
am playing this sort of mentor
type character to this
younger guy and sort
of manipulating in him and
bringing him into this world.
So that sort of
makes it seductive.
You know, when you're
reading a scene like that.
It's fun to play
that sort of thing,
to play that sort of
seductive character
and begin to control and
manipulate and mold somebody
to do things for you that
they might not normally
consider doing.
So, yeah, I mean those are
definitely acting choices.
I mean, the material
was there to work with.
I think the scene was
structured very well
and written very well.
So it just made conveying
that a lot easier,
definitely for me as an actor.
SAM ESMAIL: So did
you write that?
It was doubly intentional
because the whole
show I think is about this
guy who's trying to connect.
The whole irony of the show
is, he can't talk to people,
but he knows every personal
detail about their lives.
And so here's this guy
who is the exact opposite.
He can talk to anybody and
charismatic and he's open
and he's Christian Slater.
And he basically begins to
draw this thing out of Elliot.
CHRISTIAN SLATER:
Yeah, that is the key.
SAM ESMAIL: Get him
out of that shell.
CHRISTIAN SLATER: It was
so yin and yang there.
SAM ESMAIL: Yeah, yeah.
CHRISTIAN SLATER: That
he is so introverted,
and I'm definitely much
more outgoing and playing
that other side.
SAM ESMAIL: Yeah.
ALAN SEALES: It's
works well together.
Again bravo.
So I guess, no offense to the
USA reps standing in the back,
but this show is a lot
more edgy than anything
that I have seen
on USA thus far.
Like, you've got a little
bit of a nudity in there.
There's some shits
and some f-bombs
throughout the whole thing.
That's not going to
air like that, is that?
SAM ESMAIL: I don't know.
You should ask them.
I keep putting f-bombs
in every episode.
And--
CHRISTIAN SLATER:
Nobody's saying anything.
SAM ESMAIL: Yeah.
ALAN SEALES: Well,
they're saying f-bombs.
Well, USA isn't saying it.
SAM ESMAIL: I think they air it.
I don't know what the rules are.
I think after a
certain point, they
can't share it with
certain language.
And then they00 but
see, to me, it's
like there's always the
post-life of the show, YouTube,
excuse me, GooglePlay.
ALAN SEALES: No,
YouTube is good.
SAM ESMAIL: Hopefully we're
going to be on GooglePlay.
So yeah, things like that,
where then it's unfiltered.
But, yeah, I think for
the premier, definitely
the whole fuck society
speech, I think they're
planning on airing that.
ALAN SEALES: Oh, really?
SAM ESMAIL: I think so.
CHRISTIAN SLATER: They're
looking to push the envelope.
ALAN SEALES: Which I
think is wonderful.
SAM ESMAIL: Yeah.
CHRISTIAN SLATER: Yeah.
ALAN SEALES: Because
the show again,
this gets back to the
language in and the realism
of the whole thing.
It pulls me in when
they're talking
like they would really talk.
It's not again, while doing
the same Evil Corp stuff,
but that fit in.
But, I'm to figure out
how to formulate this.
It works for the
show because it fits.
SAM ESMAIL: Yeah.
ALAN SEALES: So I'm glad
that you're keeping it in.
Talk to the sensors, you
guys back there, good job.
Keep it in.
CHRISTIAN SLATER: Awesome.
That's been the
greatest compliment too,
to hear somebody who is
family technically savvy,
appreciating that it was handled
as accurately as possible.
I love that.
ALAN SEALES: Well, thank you,
CHRISTIAN SLATER: Yeah.
ALAN SEALES: Sam, what
else within the show
is more timely and culturally
resonant, do you think?
Like where are we going
to see the show go
that makes more sense?
SAM ESMAIL: Well,
you know again,
it's always about
people-- for me.
It's always been about
the character Elliott
and you know what he's
going to go through,
and how he's going to either
change the world or not.
But I think the
timely thing about it
is this revolutionary
spirit, that is coming about.
And it has a lot to
do with technology.
It has a lot to do
with social media.
I mean, the whole Arab
Spring happened because
of Facebook and Twitter.
And if GooglePlus
was around the time,
I'm sure would have
been on GooglePlus.
But anyway, like I think of
technology as drawing that out,
and I think beyond the
hacking part of it, which
like, let's face it, it is
kind of a superpower nowadays.
A bunch of hackers were
able to do destroy--
CHRISTIAN SLATER:
Take down a company.
SAM ESMAIL: Take down Sony
and the CEO had to step down.
That's a powerful thing.
CHRISTIAN SLATER: He that
controls the internet controls
the world.
ALAN SEALES: The Target and
the Home Depot and Sony.
SAM ESMAIL: And Obama
just got hacked.
So but beyond all
of that, I think
there is a positive thing
in that there is a way
to use technology to
really have change,
good, positive change happen.
And that to me is where I think
the show's relevance really
comes from.
ALAN SEALES: I agree.
So Christian, are you afraid to
go home and get on your Apple
IIe now?
CHRISTIAN SLATER: A little bit.
Yeah, at times.
Yeah, I'm a little
bit more nervous.
And I change my passwords a lot.
ALAN SEALES: Do you really?
CHRISTIAN SLATER: Oh,
yeah, yeah, why not?
I mean it's just the way to go.
Because like everything
is on the internet.
On the one hand, it's fantastic.
Growing up, as far as
like dealing with finances
and things like that,
this was like something
you'd have to hire a
team to work on, business
managers and now with my phone
and with these apps and things
like that, everything's
become so streamlined
I can carry it all with me.
But the danger is that
it's all out there.
ALAN SEALES: Right I
always wonder about that.
I guess no celebrities are safe.
We had the big hacking
of the celebrities.
CHRISTIAN SLATER:
Yes, actresses.
ALAN SEALES: So that was shown--
CHRISTIAN SLATER: Sure.
ALAN SEALES: So the pilot was
directed by Niels Arden Oplev.
Did I say his name right?
SAM ESMAIL: Yeah.
ALAN SEALES: So he worked on
"Girl with the Dragon Tattoo."
CHRISTIAN SLATER: He
directed that, right?
SAM ESMAIL: Yeah.
ALAN SEALES: So it's
reflected in the episode,
that it's a very
direct cinematic feel.
Did you set out writing that
writing the pilot with that
feel in mind or it it?
SAM ESMAIL: The
initial-- so when I first
start writing the script, I
was writing it as a feature.
I'd never had
television experience.
I wasn't intending to
go into television.
So I started just writing
it was my next feature film.
And I got to the about page 90,
and I realized I wasn't even
like halfway through
act one, so this
was going to either be a really
long movie that would never
get made.
Or I was like, I could
stop writing here.
And just turn it into a pilot.
So I was like,
well, that's easier.
So I'll do that.
So it has that cinematic feel
because-- and by the way,
you know, when making the
show we're continuing that on
because there is an end,
like, I had an end in mind
when I was writing the feature.
And we're still building
towards that end.
So there's not
like a-- we're not
doing this procedural thing
of like hack of the week
or anything like that.
There's a story that
were building toward.
ALAN SEALES: It's a season arc.
SAM ESMAIL: So
it's a series arc.
ALAN SEALES: Oh,
series arc, yeah.
So it's a 10 episode season.
So that's kind of
unusual too, with cable.
Cable usually does 13 or more.
SAM ESMAIL: You
know, it's funny.
So they wanted to
do thirt-- I don't
know if they wanted to do
13, but we were originally
budgeted for 13, I was the
one that wanted to do 10.
Because the naming--
this is how nerdy I am.
The naming convention
of every episode
is episode 1.0, 1.1, 1.2.
And the season finale is 1.9.
And then season two
would be 2.0 et cetera.
And when they were, like,
well you don't want to do 13?
I'm like, well then it would
screw up the whole-- Well,
then I can't--
ALAN SEALES: 1.12.
SAM ESMAIL: There would be 2.2.
And then even this screwed
it up because episode one
is 1.0 and episode two is 1.1.
And episode three is 1.2.
And people were like,
getting so confused by that.
ALAN SEALES: Techies, don't
because we start at zero.
SAM ESMAIL: Right, exactly.
And that's what I
kept saying to them.
They were like, what
are you talking about?
Can't you just name it three?
Anyway, that's just
to give you a taste.
But I kept it in there.
So we're all good.
ALAN SEALES: Good,
well, I appreciate you.
How did you get involved
with the project?
CHRISTIAN SLATER: Let's see.
I read the script.
I sat with you
and Nils and Chad.
ALAN SEALES: How did
you even get the script?
CHRISTIAN SLATER: Agent.
Yeah, I guess you
guys reached out to--
SAM ESMAIL: We did.
CHRISTIAN SLATER: To
Darren, my agent and then
we all just got together.
And with everything, I'm
always a little nervous
and a little trepidatious
to start something.
But we did sit down
and talk about it
and I had some insights into
the particular character
of Mr. Robot that I
wasn't sure were accurate.
But when I talked to Sam about
it, we both eye-to-eye on that
and I was thrilled with the
direction he was going in.
I think I did the same
thing that Elliott
does at the end of the pilot.
I threw my arms up.
I was like, cool.
That's where we're going?
Great.
I was really happy.
SAM ESMAIL: You've got
to remember, like so, I'm
writing this character
who's essentially
this crazy, anarchist
guy, big character.
And "Pump Up the
Volume," happens.
You can't get much--
I mean it was perfect.
So with the fact
that he responded,
we were sort of over
the moon about that.
ALAN SEALES: That's awesome.
CHRISTIAN SLATER:
Yeah, it's fun.
I like to be anarchist--
SAM ESMAIL: He's still doing it.
CHRISTIAN SLATER: --and a
rebel and all that stuff.
Can't let it go.
ALAN SEALES: What
are the challenges
of filming in New York,
external, exterior scenes.
CHRISTIAN SLATER: For you
guys, you were in Times Square.
SAM ESMAIL: Yeah,
that was a nightmare.
CHRISTIAN SLATER: There's a lot
of people like looking and--
ALAN SEALES: I was just
dissecting the Ferris wheels,
on the Wonder Wheel, to keep
continuity between all of that.
SAM ESMAIL: Well, we didn't.
CHRISTIAN SLATER: That was
something Nils talked about.
SAM ESMAIL: But we didn't,
well, you know what we did do,
we did the whole scene.
And it would go around twice.
So we wouldn't cut.
We would just do the
whole scene straight.
CHRISTIAN SLATER:
Actually, yeah,
in one of the first
meetings with Nils,
he did say that
yeah, he was going
to start the scene at the
start of the Ferris wheel
and then if I
messed up, we'd have
to go back to the
beginning and start again.
I was like, really?
OK.
but?
Those are challenges
that sometimes
get presented to an actor.
And you're like, all right, man.
You want to test me?
Fine.
And so I think we did it a
few times, which was great.
SAM ESMAIL: And can
I say something?
The server farm.
Like I was like, oh, this
will be an easy location.
The hardest location to get.
CHRISTIAN SLATER: Oh, yeah.
SAM ESMAIL: We
asked you guys here.
Nobody would let us
bring a camera near it.
CHRISTIAN SLATER: Near it?
SAM ESMAIL: Near it-- not even.
CHRISTIAN SLATER: Wow.
SAM ESMAIL: It was terrible.
Yeah, people are
really protective
of their physical data.
CHRISTIAN SLATER:
Their database.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah, yeah.
Were there two cameramen in
the Ferris wheel with you?
CHRISTIAN SLATER: Yeah.
SAM ESMAIL: Like you're
doing alternate shots.
CHRISTIAN SLATER: Yeah, I mean,
like that was the first scene
that we shot.
I mean it wasn't even like
on a shooting day, was it?
SAM ESMAIL: No, it
was like a pre-shoot.
CHRISTIAN SLATER: Pre-shoot.
SAM ESMAIL: But it
was a good location.
CHRISTIAN SLATER:
And it was perfect.
And it was nice
that we were, first
of all, contained in a
very small, simple space.
And you know, I mean,
it was Coney Island.
So it was beautiful
and it was easy.
And working with Rami was great.
And I think was the right
way to sort of start off.
And it felt really, really good.
And I was certainly happy
like get it behind us.
ALAN SEALES: Well,
what about the subway?
Like you just keep on
going in and eventually you
get to the end and turn around?
SAM ESMAIL: Yeah.
CHRISTIAN SLATER: Yeah.
Where was that?
SAM ESMAIL: That was in Brooklyn
on the Church Street stop.
CHRISTIAN SLATER: Yeah.
ALAN SEALES: Are you guys
responsible for the delays
that we felt?
[LAUGHING]
CHRISTIAN SLATER: Probably.
SAM ESMAIL: Because
your train had
to keep going back and forth.
CHRISTIAN SLATER: That's right.
But that actually
is an area, I guess,
which is not really
for public transport.
I think it was more
of an abandoned--
SAM ESMAIL: No, no, no.
It was a real--
CHRISTIAN SLATER:
It's a real thing?
SAM ESMAIL: It's a
real subway station.
CHRISTIAN SLATER: Oh, man.
I'm impressed.
ALAN SEALES: Was it in the
middle of the night, though?
Or at least not
during rush hour?
CHRISTIAN SLATER: No.
You know what was amazing?
It wasn't in the
middle of the night.
It was during the day.
SAM ESMAIL: It was
during the day.
Again, Nils, being
very cinematic
and wanting to get
long shots in one take,
he really put the train
conductor through his paces.
Because he would have
to- like the train
would have to hit a
specific mark each time.
ALAN SEALES: Oh, wow.
CHRISTIAN SLATER: Yeah.
I mean, all I can do is take
my hat off to those dudes.
Because they kill it.
SAM ESMAIL: They
really did, yeah.
CHRISTIAN SLATER: Had that
guy, had that conductor not
had that skill, we
would still be there.
Because that's how Nils was.
It's like if we didn't get it,
these guys hit it every time.
It was like, man, brilliant.
ALAN SEALES: So if anybody in
the audience has questions,
come up to these two microphones
in the aisles, at any point,
the ones with the lights
that like to just came up.
Or you could come and
talk into my test, which
would be awkward.
Christian, "Glass Menagerie,"
"Sideman," "Macbeth,"
"Music Man," TV, film,
God, your credits
go on forever. "Vampire," "Robin
Hood," "Prince of Thieves,"
"West Wing," "Archie,"
"Robot Chicken" voice-over,
Like your credits just
go on longer than mine.
CHRISTIAN SLATER: OK.
SAM ESMAIL: How does
this compare, how does
this role compare to the rest?
Like do you enjoy the character?
Do you enjoy the subject?
Do you enjoy the creator best?
CHRISTIAN SLATER: Yeah.
Sam is--
SAM ESMAIL: How
does it come down?
CHRISTIAN SLATER: --the best.
And we'll look, right
now, it's a fun character
to play because it's
probably-- well,
it's certainly different
for TV, comparatively
to other television projects
that I've been involved with.
It's not like he
said, an episodic.
It is a great story.
And this feels like--
television just kind of feels
like the new independent world,
in a way where you can really
hone a character and create
it and take your time.
And like he said,
we're continuing
to go with the very cinematic
feel as we shoot it.
ALAN SEALES: So the whole
season is the same--
CHRISTIAN SLATER: Same tone?
ALAN SEALES: Same one, yeah.
CHRISTIAN SLATER: I think so.
SAM ESMAIL: Yeah.
CHRISTIAN SLATER: He's
maintaining that consistently,
beautifully.
So look, like I said I
love the mysteriousness
of the character.
And I'm looking forward
to seeing where it goes.
I mean, it's definitely--
he's a very creative man
and I think there will be
some interesting surprises.
SAM ESMAIL: He doesn't
know all the answers.
ALAN SEALES: Oh no?
CHRISTIAN SLATER: That's true.
SAM ESMAIL: It's all
up there, locked away?
CHRISTIAN SLATER:
It's all locked away
in the safe between his ears.
Yes.
ALAN SEALES: So you've-- you're
now a first time director?
You've directed a few episodes?
SAM ESMAIL: I directed
the second episode.
ALAN SEALES: Oh, the second, OK.
So what was that like for you?
SAM ESMAIL: It was great.
I mean, I directed
a feature last year.
So it wasn't my
first time directing,
but it was my first time
directing television.
And really is like
Christian said,
it has that Indie
filmmaking kind of spirit.
Because you have
to go really fast.
There's not a lot of time.
There's not like every
resource known to man.
But we're also not
shooting a procedural,
where you're just on
the set and there's
like 20 pages of dialogue.
We're doing a lot like
creative cinematic things.
CHRISTIAN SLATER:
Like the angles
are very interesting
and the lighting.
And I'm really happy about that.
ALAN SEALES: So do you don't
know everything of where
your character is going?
CHRISTIAN SLATER: No.
ALAN SEALES: How
much knowledge do you
give him when he's
asking about the future,
how to play scenes
now in relating
to how it's going to play out?
SAM ESMAIL: Well, I kind of--
CHRISTIAN SLATER: He
gives me just enough.
SAM ESMAIL: Yeah.
I kind of give him enough to
know what to do in the episode.
ALAN SEALES: Is there a reason
to keep it to yourself, though?
Like shouldn't the cast know
where their character's going?
SAM ESMAIL: Well, there's
a lot of-- I don't know.
That's not necessarily
the best thing
to know, to know
where they end up.
You know what I mean?
CHRISTIAN SLATER: You
don't want to give
an actor too much information.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
CHRISTIAN SLATER: You really
don't You really don't.
Like Woody Allen works--
SAM ESMAIL: No, he doesn't
even give them the script.
He gives them the pages of
the scene the day of the--
ALAN SEALES: It's
kind of like I think
"The Walking Dead" cast too.
They're like, yeah,
I didn't die today.
CHRISTIAN SLATER: Yes.
SAM ESMAIL: Absolutely
CHRISTIAN SLATER:
All right, man.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for having
it be very realistic,
including shooting in New York.
I was trying to find out what
trains that you guys are at.
Before but on the
technical side,
I know that's what
drew me in too.
It was more accurate than 95%
of what's out there right now,
in terms of TV shows.
Why is that?
What was the difference
that you guys go through
that every other show
just doesn't try to do?
SAM ESMAIL: I mean
my personal theory--
you're talking
about why they don't
do that, why other shows don't
do that or why we do that?
AUDIENCE: Well, yeah.
Why do you guys do that
and why do other's not?
SAM ESMAIL: Because
I think it's corny.
When I watch these other
shows and they're like,
the one thing they
can think of is,
we have to grow
graphics at the person.
And they're like doing
this on the keyboard,
and they're like just--
CHRISTIAN SLATER:
Inside the computer.
SAM ESMAIL: Yeah,
I don't get it.
I'm m if you actually
do the real thing,
I think it's very compelling.
To me that's still
very compelling.
And also hacking is not just
about being on the keyboard.
There's a lot of
social engineering
that's involved in
trying to figure out
what a person's
password might be
or how to find the
hole in what they trust
to get inside their network or
their email or whatever it is.
So I honestly, I just find
it way more compelling
I don't find cheesy CGI graphics
that make no sense all that
interesting.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Thank you.
SAM ESMAIL: You're welcome.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah, question.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
again a lot of fun.
Thank you very much
for showing this.
One thing I was curious about
was with the subway scene,
the extent to which
your character is
like sort of explicitly
quoting and has
a relationship with like
other hacker movies,
because it sounded a bit
almost like "The Matrix" scene,
like oh, I'm going to take
you to the Rabbit Hole
instead of to Brooklyn.
SAM ESMAIL: Yeah, yeah.
AUDIENCE: I'm curious to what
extent like your character
sees that he's sort of quoting
some of this stuff or--
SAM ESMAIL: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --echoing it
on a more meta level.
SAM ESMAIL: No.
I mean.
Meta, sure whatever.
Or you could say I just
ripped one of the lines off.
But because they are--
I'm a huge "Matrix" fan
and I always wanted to like--
there was always an homage--
and I don't even know if
it's subconscious or not.
Because I feel like
I've forgotten if I did.
But there is one line in the
show, where he says something,
where it says in
the Ferris wheel,
there's something that control--
I can't quote the line,
but I think it is what,
not Neil, Morpheus,
it's what Morpheus says to--
CHRISTIAN SLATER: Yeah.
SAM ESMAIL: I swear that's it.
I think.
But I'm just a big
fan of that movie.
So I had to.
CHRISTIAN SLATER: Me too.
Oh, gosh.
SAM ESMAIL: It's a great film.
CHRISTIAN SLATER: I love it.
I love it.
ALAN SEALES: One of
my favorite quotes
is, "money hasn't been
real since we got off
the gold standard.
It's become virtual,
software, the operating
system of our world.
We're on the verge of taking
down this virtual reality."
I love that one.
SAM ESMAIL: I'm pretty
sure that was me.
ALAN SEALES: Question.
AUDIENCE: So you just picked
up on the social aspects
of hacking.
So the character is socially
awkward, on the one hand.
But on the other hand,
you put in those moments
where he is actually doing
social hacking or engineering
and he's asking his victim
for certain details, which
is great.
So there's really this
part where the character
is socially awkward, but
then when he hits his stride,
when he is in his element,
that just drops away.
He's doing the social hacking.
He did that in the cafe
scene in the beginning.
He did that later on with this
partner of a psychiatrist.
Can you explain
a little bit more
about how you wrote that in?
SAM ESMAIL: So it's
about vulnerabilities,
which also another, I guess
technology term or hacker term.
So I think Elliot-- and I think
this is true again for people
that I know who
are also hackers.
Like they are confident
when it comes to their work,
less so when it comes
to being vulnerable,
showing something about who
they are, because that's
where their insecurities lie.
And honestly, it's
such a weird parallel
because that's the thing hackers
look for, vulnerabilities.
And that's the thing that
they always try and protect.
So yeah, when he's
supremely confident,
and he's like playing a
character to these people,
he can talk and
he can be social,
because he knows that he's
not having to open up.
But when he's confronted with
Angela or Ollie or anybody
who wants to try and actually
get to know the real Eliot,
that's when he freezes
up and can't function.
ALAN SEALES: Well, we are
running short on time,
so I'm going to wrap it up
soon unless nobody else has
any more questions.
I want to touch real quick
on the theme of women
in technology.
Because you have
two very strong--
I assume Angela is
the do-gooder better.
And then we have Darlene
is the do-badder.
SAM ESMAIL: Right
ALAN SEALES: So we have
two equally strong women
in technology.
Was that as that
on purpose as well?
SAM ESMAIL: Yeah.
ALAN SEALES: I mean,
Google specifically
is trying to do a lot of public
outreach to do diversity.
SAM ESMAIL: And then we
have, in later episodes,
a Sheryl Sandberg-type
character that's coming up.
So it was done on purpose,
but not necessarily
because I'm trying
to be more equal to--
I didn't even consciously
think about it like that.
I think that's just
life right now.
There are female hackers.
There are females in technology.
So I just thought, make this
as authentic as possible.
And this was part
of the authenticity.
ALAN SEALES: Cool.
All right.
So lastly then, if
you could summarize
for everybody-- everybody
who's in technology, of course,
is to love this.
But for everybody who isn't,
what's going to appeal to them?
Why should they watch this?
SAM ESMAIL: You want
me want to do that?
CHRISTIAN SLATER:
No, you can start.
SAM ESMAIL: You're
Christian Slater.
I would say, you
know, look, at the end
of the day, whether it's about
hacking or cops or lawyers
or whatever, at the end
the day, it's about people.
And I think if someone's
going to watch this,
it's because they like Elliot.
They relate to
him on some level.
They relate to Mr. Robot.
They get enjoyment out
of him on some level.
They know a crazy uncle who's
like-- You know what I mean?
That's sort of what
happens, is that
your personal-- the
characters come off as
real people in your life.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah.
I think it helps too,
to that point, that you
make so many references
to real things
that everyone can
relate to something.
Like, I like "Hunger Games"
and I own a BlackBerry.
So everybody's got something.
SAM ESMAIL: Or I hate Apple.
ALAN SEALES: I hate--
I didn't say that.
Any, yeah, so if nobody
has any more questions,
we'll wrap it up.
Please everybody, put
your hands together
for Sam Esmail and
Christian Slater.
SAM ESMAIL: Thank you.
CHRISTIAN SLATER: Thank you.
ALAN SEALES: "Mr. Robot"
premieres Wednesday,
June 24 on USA, 10:00 PM
Eastern, 9:00 Central,
#mrrobot.
Go out and watch it.
Tell your friends.
[APPLAUSE]